هربت الشهر منذ ان اصدر ستار على
الانتخابات النصفيه في امريكا لتظهر بعضها
عده اشكاليه اخرها طرح امام المحكمه
العليا
اثار ملف قانون انتخابي مخاوف الشديده لدى
اليسار وتيارات اخرى كونه قد يحدث ثوره في
تنظيم انتخابات الرئاسه والكونغرس
ستركز جلسه الاستماع امام المحكمه العليا
الامريكيه على نظريه قانونيه جديده
اقترحها اعضاء الكونجرس الجمهوريون في ضعف
كارولا ويبث فيها يونيو القادم
والتي اذا تمت تمنيها ستمدح المشرعين في
جميع الولايات ال 50 حريه تنظيم
الانتخابات
بمهمه تحديده وقتي ومكان واجراءات
الاقتراع ما سمح لهم باتخاذ قرارات بشان
التصويت بالبريد والساعات عمل مكاتب
الاقتراع والوثائق التي يجب تقديمها
للتسجيل في القوائم الانتخابيه مع ذلك
تخضع قوانينهم للمراجعه من قبل المحاكم
المحليه وقد يستخدم حاكم الولايه حق النقض
هذا ما يريد النواب المنتخب
تغييره فبالنسبه اليهم الدستور يضع تنظيم
الانتخابات الفيدراليه في ايدي مشرعي
الولايات دون غيرهم هذا التفسير المتطرف
للدستور سيساعد النواب المحليين على حرمان
بعض الناخبين من حق التصويت وتقسيم
الدوائر الانتخابيه كما يرون ذلك مناسبا
ومن المحتمل ان يؤدي الى تخريب نتيجه
الانتخابات
الديمقراطيون في نظريه الولايات المستقله
محاوله جمهوريه للتلاعب بالعمليه
الانتخابيه للتحقيق مكاسب سياسيه امام
المحافظون فيرون ان النظام السياسي سيعاني
بشكل كبير اذا ترك تحديد الدوائر
الانتخابيه خارج نطاق السيطره